[Music]
this is solidcast number 12. my name is
John Striker Meyer and I'm here today as
your host for sawcast number 12. and
with this production is coming to you
courtesy of Jocko willing Productions
and his right hand man Echo Charles and
of course today we're also joined by our
secret
secret technician here Tom good morning
Tom good morning and so with that I'm
going to turn to Across the fence
let's talk a little bit about our secret
war and this was in May 1968
a team had been distracted from an LZ a
landing Zone
but it wasn't clear if the entire team
was out or not
and so on that occasion the king bee the
South Vietnamese helicopter was ordered
to return to the LZ and on it we had one
Staff Sergeant Robert J Parks who was on
that helicopter going into the LZ
and because no one had radio Covey to
indicate the team was clear from the
target
spider
directed The Chase ship to land on the
LZ to ensure that St Oregon was
extracted successfully
it was also a last Act of desperation
he had hoped Against All Odds to see
Lane
Robert Duval Owen or one of the
Vietnamese team members of St Idaho
no one saw
Spider jumped aboard the h-34 as they
moored around exploded
and the bomb creator and dozens of
weapons fired upon the king bee
as the chopper was lifting off the door
gunner sitting next to spider parks was
killed
and this was one mission on one day May
of 68 and today it is my extreme
pleasure
to introduce Robert J Spider parks to
sarcast number 12 spider
welcome to the sarcast thank you teal
and uh
on the we started in the middle of one
of those exceptional days where
um
we didn't talk about
St Idaho but that time we had Recon
teams previously you had been on a
member of Spike team Idaho you had run
several missions with the that team
Glenn Lane was the 1-0
that's right and at that point you had
been promoted to your own team you
earned a new promotion so you get
transferred from Idaho
Lane goes out with a new team member
Robert Duvall Owen and that team goes
missing in action May 22nd 1968 and they
remain missing in action today
they are amongst the 50 Green Berets
from
the secret war in Laos Cambodia
and amongst the
1583 Americans who are still missing an
action today in Southeast Asia from the
secret War so getting back to that day
the um a standard operating procedure if
a team disappears or is in severe
trouble there's a bright light and a
bright light is an emergency insertion
by a Recon team in this case it was
Spike team Oregon with George Sternberg
who if you haven't seen it was on
sawcast one
and he talked about that day in
extensive detail from his point of view
he was Mike Tucker and Steve Perry were
the Americans with four or five
indigenous troops from Spike team Idaho
they went in looking for Idaho they
found no one
they had heavy contact everybody was
wounded they had one of their team
members was killed in action
the team was pulled out and this was the
scene where you go in and that moment in
time just one day where uh you're riding
in the chase ship and we've never heard
your side but that brief time on the
ground I can't imagine all the bullets
being shot around you as you went over
you talk a little bit about how you
landed and then what you saw or didn't
see and of course like we said you were
hoping to see somebody from Idaho but
you didn't
well tell let me back up a little bit I
was still assigned to RT Idaho my
promotion was pending I was to go down
to another uh fob and and take charge of
what they call a leloy team leloy was a
famous uh warrior in the old Vietnamese
Tribal wars and I hadn't left the
compound I was still assigned to
hearty Idaho I was supposed to go on
that mission and Lane said spider you're
getting promoted you get ready to go
down to Contin
and uh
Owen is ready and we had Owen had
trained with us he'd had another tour
and ahead of that and was ready to go
and Lane said you know you need you need
to stay here and prepare to go this you
know I'll take oh and Owen was ready so
I was okay with that uh and then when we
didn't hear from them uh I be became
adamant that I wanted to go and then uh
Colonel Bill Shelton said spider you
you can go on the chase ship I said okay
that'll be enough
and that's why I was on the chase ship
and of course uh I had a radio
uh but I could I could only pick up the
fox mic I couldn't hear the UHF and the
VHF for the spads and the uh and of
course my Vietnamese wasn't good enough
it was good enough to tell the the pilot
we go down now anyway uh
the uh
they'll see there were there was plenty
of smoke down there but we we landed we
came in and uh just for clarity you you
told the king bee to go down after
Sternberg was out so that team is out no
no you didn't know they where were you
they were still
they were still on the ground okay and
we didn't know and I didn't know what
the what the uh aviators were talking
about right and then I I'd heard that uh
uh the fox Mike broadcast that you know
they were they were the uh
the king bees were coming in for pickup
so we were right behind them
and and of course Sternberg and the team
were were at the bomb crater I believe
and they he was
he had
Steve Perry because I think Tucker was
wounded also
but uh there was some confusion there
and then Steve was seriously injured yep
he was paralyzed when he went down at
that moment
yeah he he had had one of the m26s or
concussion concussion grenades that had
landed in there but I landed about 40
meters from that bomb crater
and was running over the other
toward them when the when he had thrown
or just well tossed
Steve Perry on on the aircraft and he
had been shot in the arm I could see him
waving and it looked like that he was
flipping him off with his with his free
hand and sturberg got shot in the right
arm in the right arm but he's
left-handed he's left-handed so he's
shooting if he still found time to flip
the bird to the NVA that's one of those
golden moments in Sonic history and of
course I talked to Sternberg after that
but after that incident they were all
metal back back to
fubai
I had some scrap Mel in the arm and
stuff it was minor stuff and the and
they couldn't take me at the fob because
the dispensary was full
and they they took me off down to the
mass unit down in down the street Bill
Shelton was on the PSP pads when we came
back to fubai and he said hey spot are
you going down there and take care of
that [ __ ] so and that's what it was but
and then I came back and found out that
they had been further meta back down to
Danang or I don't know if they went all
the way back to Camp Zama
but about
a month later we went down to be
interviewed by some uh by some Intel
types down in Saigon and Saigon had been
recently hit with uh with a sapper
attacks and we stayed at the safe house
or I stayed at the safe house house 10
and then I went out to the uh
to the liaison board where Pappy Webb
was out there and I knew I could get
some alcohol and and poker so I I went
in they didn't really want to talk to me
much about about what went on and uh
in the white bright light uh LZ okay but
I gave them that report I don't know
what happened to it so let's back the
tape up a little bit further then uh
when did you land in South Vietnam
and uh this is after of course uh just
for the record you and I met in the
summer of 1967 a company special forces
training group along with Tony Harrell
Rick Estes Rick Howard and a few other
luminaries Ron Owens but we went through
training group together you and I played
in the same softball team with Tony and
we played against John McIntyre from
Company B beat them profoundly so and uh
thanks to your pitching skills and uh so
we had we knew each other from training
group and so uh when you landed in
Vietnam I was still going through some
TDY training back in the States but when
did you land in Vietnam dude how when
did you get assigned up to fob one
I landed in Vietnam
just just after Ted of
68 and I
I had gone v-o-c-o
to up to fob 1 by way of fob 3 in
caisson
and I I had been reading about Cason in
the in the front page news about this
Siege and I said you know
that's why my dad said don't volunteer
for nothing
and uh at any rate I met troll Sternberg
up there a few days before I was able to
get out of Cason and and uh that is
another experience that I was so glad I
was assigned to fob1 how long were you
at kson about a week
that's a week too long right yes it was
I I could tell you a little story of
what happened uh I was I was on a king
bee and I had a I had an M16 and a
duffel bag full of new
uh
sterile fatigues that had no red dirt on
them and I looked around the guy that
was on the the chopper with me was a guy
named Valentine and he looked completely
red dirt and mud and if he he needed to
save
it yeah that from Cason he'd been on
he'd been down to to uh Saigon and was
coming back up anyway
here's what it's like
the helicopter said we go down now and
they just it's like being on a roller
coaster they they go down and then about
12 feet 10 feet off the ground I saw my
duffel bag go out and it's going end
over in I looked around and said this is
not my stop and of course the
the door the door Gunners pushed me out
and and they did not want to stay long
so I found my duffel bag and nobody was
out then
a hand comes up out of out of a bunker
and says hey hey you hey
expletive yes come over here run
run mother sticker and and so I start
running over there and I hear this poem
in the background and everybody's
underground and those are 122 Rockets or
mortars coming off of cold Rock Mountain
which is right outside of Cason but that
that was my introduction to be to
Vietnam really
and the reason why the king bee didn't
stay very long is because at that point
in time during that Ted offensive any
any aircraft that landed there generated
enemy gunfire mortars or in this case
120. that's the Airfield you could see
the remnants of a c-47 blown apart and
you could see that on on the ground you
knew that hey this is Indian Territory
and I say that with respect to Indians
and we'll get into that later on if you
want to we absolutely will talk a little
bit more about the Comanche experience
but getting back to uh RT Idaho as Idaho
so you get back to fubai and somebody
says through the process introduces you
to Glenn Lane
how's that work
the sergeant major
sergeant major in Enriquez at the time
uh called us in and he said uh
I forget
we had started off from from the sfob in
natrang that was about 15 people when I
got up there there was about four of us
on a chopper and the sergeant major said
uh any of you had any Recon experience
and of course I said well I was in a
Recon reconnaissance troop in in the
49th Armored Division when it was
activated at Fort Polk and I have a look
some experience in that and I was also
on alert with the 16th infantry Rangers
and he was smiling he said we got a
place for you spider but anyway it
wasn't spider at the time right but I I
messed up
but Enriquez was a super sergeant major
as as were all of them there that we had
yet so he then assigns you or to RT
Idaho right uh one of the uh one of the
former members had uh Gone on their
mission and decided that it wasn't for
him
and of course there was nothing
derogatory but they got him out of the
fob
uh post taste well not not soon enough
uh to other lane uh Lane had to had
filled me in and said hey uh you know
he's leaving and here's why anyway and
more importantly you're on a team you
get introduced to the team and between
that time and may of 68 you ran several
missions with Glenn Lane as the one zero
and uh now I read as the one one yeah
that lane was the one zero yeah the one
one we had several hey you missions we
had to experience uh before you got
there uh uh had to fill in for a guy on
the hatchet Force but I went on
two bright lights that I remember well
two Bright Lights yeah one of them was
down uh hey you down pilot right outside
of Hanoi and uh I think I gave a
a story about this in John plester's
book about a MIG 21 flying underneath us
and and uh one of the guys don't see if
that's uh talking to I said Lane what
what would you do if you saw a MIG and
he said well that's it and he said well
you better start because that's a MIG
anyway if something to that tune but I I
didn't really want to open up to John
plaster because I didn't know him right
but he was certainly a great Covey
writer and a 1-0 in his own right and he
did so much research there that I didn't
feel the things I did were important
enough to be in that book well and just
for the record we have interviewed John
and he will be on he was on podcast
number 11. sarcast number 11. and yes he
did three tours of Duty and uh our
listeners will enjoy that tape but
getting back to spider Parks through so
that's one bright light just outside of
Hanoi
were you able to get to the pile
we did no kidding we had a heavy team we
we put up a there was no one around it
and and we couldn't get the pilot out
uh
this is probably not probably not uh
appropriate to talk about but we have
things called crispy Critters right and
that's what uh you know jet fuel can do
and and if you want you want to take
parts of that human remains out of that
cockpit that would have been all we'd
been able to do and and Elaine chose not
to do it I believe it was appropriate
yeah you're able to confirm the status
of the pilot the pilot was was was
confirmed dead and uh you know I don't
know what the status
that the family got but uh yeah again
they have this they have this status now
with the dpaa that is uh
uh confirmed dead BNR body not recovered
and the body may have not been recovered
because of the elements because of the
because it of the crispy Critter mode
and and uh
another great Aviator as you and I know
we'd be fertilizer in Southeast Asia if
it wasn't for the great aviators without
a doubt yeah absolutely okay I've talked
too much I'm sorry no that's why you're
here because we're paying you the big
bucks for that talk and we appreciate
that Jocko Productions appreciate you
taking the time to talk to us today
absolutely well I'll be glad to meet
Jocko in the paycheck thank you
but I'd like to go back
um to the very beginning when you talk
to your sergeant major and explained
about your history a little bit because
this is a very unique time uh for your
in your life and
um you joined the army around
56 57 56 and 57 58 and
um just tell us a little bit about a
couple of units you had a very unique uh
company Commander at one point but uh I
I wanted you to tell us about that so
it's accurate
company Commander well the 16th
Jack the guy was a battle group
Commander he was a full Colonel he was
an OSS combat veteran a very famous uh
General
uh Jackson who lives in Franklin
Tennessee today lives in Franklin
Tennessee
still alive I worked for him at three
different occasions during my 30 years
of or more or less
but I was in the Army Reserve when I
came to Vietnam which is not unique and
of course nowadays I had volunteered to
go back on active duty in 1967 to go
through operations and intelligence
school and and get my full flash for
Special Forces but it wasn't my first
time with special forces or Rangers or
Special Operations
indeed
so you had that earlier time with those
companies and that's what led to that
experience that yeah I was I was sent to
bad toast Germany in 1959 at as a Como
person
and a uh a long-range Patrol type Ranger
type
and of course batos at that time was the
headquarters for test Special Forces
tenth Special Forces Group the Nicole
war was at in full
in Berlin and I was privy to all of that
and and of course Colonel feisenheimer I
believe was the was the group commander
of the 10th group and uh there's some
people that met me that are still alive
uh uh
another another American Indian uh I
call him a drugstore Indian but but he's
he's uh uh that's Luke Emanuel he knew
me at at the 10th group when a lot of
people said spider couldn't have been
there but anyway right
so most of the most of the things that
are
not easily explained
can be backed up by you know by the
appropriate liar
[Laughter]
but also so let's so you can talk to
you're not a a store Indian you're the
real deal no I'm not I'm I'm a park
breed but I have lived on a reservation
I slept with the horses I grew up and
and uh chewed that dirt with but the
reservation we're we're on no longer
exist it was uh it was kind of like a
gypsy uh Gypsy band there were Comanches
Apaches navajos hoopys Zuni's and all
kinds of Mexican and Mexican Indians uh
who my first language was
Comanche second language was slang
Spanish
third language was broken English and
profanity so which I'm still proficient
at very proficient and since then you've
also added how many more languages
Korean
I learned German from being in Germany
and I went to a small German course I
went to the Defense Language Institute
on three occasions I learned Korean uh
a limited fluency Russian and advanced
Spanish Advanced yeah and you know from
that time on on your on the reservation
that also LED
you to an experience where your time
with horses and working with indigenous
people really pay it off and you this is
like a little sidebar before we get back
to Vietnam but just one of those
interesting stories where because you
grew up with horses on one of your
assignments you were
encountered horses and could you just
talk a little bit about that for a quick
sidebar okay well trying to make it we
were in Colombia training the
anti-terrorists in in Bogota Colombia uh
training the police and military
they had a stable there they had we were
doing a training exercise and and my
commander was down there with us and uh
some of the people on our
our uh
special ops team that one of our
companies had the same Mission as Delta
Force has for the Central and South
America and
many of the were had some experience
with horses the sergeant major at that
time
a friend of mine who went through o and
I with me in 67. lost an eye in Vietnam
with SOG
Francisco Medina he I know
we were pretty much accomplished
Horsemen and several of the other guys
were but the other guys
they really couldn't go with us to to
help out with this exercise we were on
and that sort of bonded with the uh with
the people we were working with
in Colombian Bogota at that time
and you're in the mountains you're
working with some local business people
where we had later on
and around I was in the 80s when the
Palace of a Justice was came down
uh that contact that our company had
with those people and my commander
I'm not sure if this is still classified
but
the the takedown of the uh of the Palace
of Justice
uh the third of the seventh had a lot to
do with that so enough enough said well
maybe we'll we'll come back a little
later but but here the key element was
on this exercise you and a couple other
special forces soldiers yes worked with
the indigenous troops and your
experiences with horses helped you to
ingratiate yourself establish report or
tilt indeed but that's that's just like
one of the little sidebars yeah well you
know and that's not unheard of the folks
in Iraq and Afghanistan uh some of the
reserve Special Forces guys were were
really into that that uh you know The
Horse Soldiers and my heart goes out to
them they're you know I salute them yeah
whereas the majority of the people in
the horse story horse Soldier Story they
weren't Horsemen you guys were and it
helped to ingratulate you with the
people you're working I think some of
those guys were Horsemen they had skills
there were a few well I must tell you
this my father was in the horse calvary
he was in the Old Guard is that right
yes that's right
tell me more
that's enough that's enough okay well
that's an Arlington Cemetery but he he
was in the horse cavalry I
of course uh our our family is so
dysfunctional which nowadays that's
that's
you know uh that that's a uh uh mental
health term and it's but it's
appropriate
indeed but so uh we took that a little
sidebar so let's get back to Vietnam
back to F of B1
uh St RT Idaho is now missing in action
they come to you say spider you're not
going to go to contou
we're going to make you to 1-0 of Idaho
and that's where you and I met or we met
actually let's back up a little let's
back that's why I pay you the big bucks
Colonel Shelton Carnival Roy Barr
major jacks
uh major Clyde sincere said spider you
want to keep Idaho the name of Idaho and
stay on Idaho or you want to change the
name I went to The Interpreter because
here's the word and and I'll say this a
little bit I had some notes here but
I've had a Charmed Life
so has hit our interpreter he and I for
some reason he wasn't on that mission I
was not on that mission and the other
folks that are assigned to Idaho uh foul
and Foo people that you met later on
they determined that spider's lucky he
ain't good but he's lucky
and and of course they knew that I had
some Recon skills because I believe I
did and we uh we improved on
the
SOP that lane had so hardly worked on or
not hardly worked on but so worked on so
hard and one of the things that we
always all of the teams that Network
together and got in at you know after
duty or it when appropriate to to think
about hey what works in the bush man
what are you doing right right and we
shared those things and that would be
the main sharing ground would be the
clubhouse yeah or the mess hall or a
mess all the best all and and or out
there on in the company uh gravel pit or
yard of the firing range wherever but we
shared that information and and one of
the things was stay off trails you know
yeah yeah and we'll talk about that
later on sure but at any rate we came
back uh I took hip with me and I said
hey
hell no we're keeping Idaho's our team
and we're going to keep it and then a
few days later you came in or you were
already there you passed RT I'd a whole
going out on that mission you might want
to talk about that
well we've mentioned it before quickly
when I landed fob 1 me Johnny McIntyre
and John Hutchins uh the three of us the
king B came in landed and of course that
was our first time we ever flew in a
king bee and they gave us that
initiation come up Highway One heading
north flip it on its side it's like holy
[ __ ] what's going on but we survived
that we landed Idaho gets on and
disappears into history song history a
tragic chapter therein and uh so they
disappear they attempt to find them they
can't the bright light gets shot up
you're on the ground with the shrapnel
wounds Etc and then you become the one
zero and the thing I remember is that
training you and of course Don wolfen
was the assistant team leader and uh uh
he he came on the team and that's when
we started all that training and you
just worked us I
worked as hard then we had the monsoons
the bags and then our uh we did a
practice Mission a nighty Ambush and
then we had our first real mission where
you're the one zero and they augmented
the team to insert Air Force sensors
into the asphalt we had one more prior
to that foreign they sent that team in
with us they got in a fire fight you
told me that was a practice Mission it
wasn't for you it was for real it was on
the east side no it was it was real
but you're done good boy
I may be slow but I got there
uh yes and the other team that was
parallel to us they ambushed to pass
that loud Ambush they uh they got run
out
after they ambushed the Ambush they they
got they got run out and we stayed in
another couple of nights and and uh the
the headset thought we were great but
you know we were just kind of uh moving
around in place and and not uh you know
not not really uh moving too far but uh
we were told just you just go in there
and
we did we just did have a little
remember that area we landed on where
where we won't go into any more about
that but it was it was a big open area
and they had something like a gravel
road we watched that road a little bit
we did I remember that part and then
that was my first exposure to Laotian
the mosquitoes in the morning I could
barely open my eyes I had been eaten
alive by the mosquitoes well you you
guys from New Jersey just didn't didn't
have it all together we didn't we're
just the City Slickers
so after that first successful Mission
which I thought was a practice Mission
All Those Years thank you for the
clarification Sergeant
um then the Air Force sensors and that
missing you're the one zero augmented
with les Daniels from uh uh RT Rhode
Island and then we had Bob Ross came in
from S3 and I forget why those two
gentlemen had worked with the equipment
and they were there to augment the team
but you were the one zero took us in and
maybe talk a little bit about what that
mission work we had the main computer
all everything was buried and then two
more coaxial cables that went out to
lesser sensors that could pick up motion
on the trail well that's why Ross and
and I believe I don't know if it's Hal
Falk the other guy but but
less Daniel was was with us to insert
right okay but we inserted them they
turned them on and made sure that we
didn't screw them up right and they were
out there you know to to do that but uh
they said spider you're going to be in
charge you're going to be the one one
zero I said okay I said I'd I'd rather
not go out with someone you know that
maybe their first second mission on the
ground or whatever but Ross and Falk
were great people and and they they
helped us but you remember when we
buried those things there was an antenna
sticking up right
and when we the reason we didn't get
killed on the way in is because they
couldn't lower the AAA guns low enough
they they thought the 101st was coming
in and they were going to be coming in
at 3 000. that's the reason we came in
right off the and remember you guys had
your last rights the night before
because we're going to land on the Ho
Chi Minh trail and we're we're gonna end
the answer yeah yeah we're pretty
certain we were really good day 24 hours
yeah and the the reason we got in it is
out is because we came in low that was
with the first cabinet missing
no that was the 101st the Choppers might
have been from the first calf okay but
the 101st came in and remember we went
up to LZ by Stone right we laid there
and we were panting you know drinking
water and here's the funny story that I
remember
they had a they had a tent up there and
Here Comes This Captain with a flak
jacket and a steel pot and running over
to where we were laying there on the
ground you know getting our breasts back
said who are these people where are your
steel pots where are your flak jackets
my God you haven't saved
yes who's in charge here and
and I believe it was you thought but
that'd be spider he said spider who is
spider what and anyway he's a you know I
get up I I didn't call him sir or
anything we were in sterile fatigues and
he looked around at all our little
people with gold teeth and and uh
better weapons than they had absolutely
the car 15s yeah and he said who what
what's going on who's in charge here and
then here comes a major
out of the headquarters says
horse spider General theis wants to talk
to spider and then this Captain almost
locked his heels he said so I went over
there and and what he's telling me he
said
he said maybe
five minutes after you put those sensors
in we started picking up Transmissions I
don't know if they were deer or rabbits
or or NVA coming but we got is that you
guys did a great job get on out of here
but that was that that was the 101st
Commander yeah I'd forgotten that to
please yeah but don't you remember that
time Captain running over oh yeah well
maybe it wasn't you it may not have been
another way might have been might have
might have been Daniels
but Daniels is another American Indian
he's the he's a ute is that right yep
right out of Colorado I got to I got to
link up with him later on so oh no
kidding because Les Daniels was for the
record probably one of if not the best
one zeros in Camp better than me yeah
better in office for sure great guy
um so then in September Idaho put in
another set of sensors up by case on I
forget were you the one zero for that no
I was nothing no no no it must have been
Don walking or or you no not not me it
was Don because uh yeah that was
September up by Highway nine Idaho
became sort of a a uh uh best horse uh
use you know
use your best donkeys and and uh guys
that seem to have a Charmed
uh existence well we ran that mission
and also during that time we had some
monsoons so the team was inactive a lot
of Duty in in the camp and then finally
we come to uh October the 5th
when St Alabama is inserted and uh they
had an inexperienced 1-0
the team leader and they went in with a
nine-man team
the second helicopter went in with Lynn
black and some indigenous troops from St
Alabama and Lynn told the inexperienced
1-0 there's a NVA flag here's at least a
battalion we're nine we should leave now
the Vietnamese team members told the 1-0
we should leave now he said no
and then he committed to mortal sin
which we referenced earlier he walked
out he led the team down a trail they
walked into an L-shaped Ambush where
they were ambushed by 50 NVA killing two
members of the team right away the team
leader who made the wrong decision and
tragically a really good point man was
killed instantly firefight went on it
commenced all day
at this point yourself and spider Parks
uh Spider Parks you are Pat Watkins were
flying Covey that day for the entire day
re laying combo from the team on the
ground with Lynn black talking to you
and you and or Pat Watkins directing air
strikes all day and uh
first just we've talked about it a
little bit in the book across the fence
but for you what a couple things that
stick out in your mind and then I think
it was near the end of the day you had
one of those moments in life that you'll
never forget
we almost had a mid-air Collision
well first of all tip we uh
I was flying Covey we were both out
there uh when I was a Covey writer I was
I'm not a cubby pilot cubby Pilots could
do everything that covered Riders could
do and more and but here's the thing Pat
was
was I believe he was with uh
uh Covey two five six maybe two five
four uh
they were they're about Bingo on gas and
they couldn't stay as long as Bingo
means lower fuel yep yep anyway he uh
he had we had told
James stride and duck
go out on a VR and you pick your own LZ
don't don't pick the one that's that's
been appointed for you and we think that
there's a mole somewhere and if we
shared that information I said uh even
that early in May yeah wow but but even
uh the the fact that uh
he did not want to listen to us really
uh detrimental to what happened to the
you know to that team and then I got the
uh I I got on the horn or on the fox mic
radio with Lynn black and he's saying
the one two was down I think he's dead
and then I Lynn will tell you this that
I told him said well check him out
because you're not a Medicare you're now
anyways
come find out he wasn't he was not dead
he was praying and of course
that's not the time you need to put that
in a different compartment get on but
there are so many things that went wrong
the weather was bad they went in a hole
and aircraft was stacked up high and
that's why we almost had a mid-air
collision with too many aircraft in
there and of course Pat Watkins I and I
were both over Jolly Green 1-0
which was piloted by
a
an air a pilot from the great Services
known as the Coast Guard
and we watched that b40 rocket as it
went into that Chopper didn't
a dive flip flipped over and crashed
into the jungle
and the arc10 radio the emergency radio
came up I thought no one could have
survived that crash and it was the PJ
off of jolly green 1-0
and of course that story in your book
takes up a lot of
appropriate time to to deal with it
correctly and and I'll never forget that
day but I'll never forget the day that
that uh Elaine and no one were missing
there are several other turning points
uh marble mountain of course and and uh
New Year's day seems like
uh a lot of a lot of things happened
I agree we're going to go to each one of
those so but the specificity for that
one moment in time people hear about Tac
Air cover
working at how difficult it is and like
you said on that day uh the team was in
trouble early in the morning they were
on the ground the entire day until you
all got them out you and Pat working
with all the air assets which includes
A1 Sky breeders Air Force fast movers we
lost another king bee that jolly green
went down a second jolly green was shot
up so bad after they extracted and they
have four and did they lose enough I
believe they did but we got them out at
last light right Watkins had had to go
back for gas if you remember absolutely
yeah and but what Watkins is much better
recovery Rider than me he's he's he's
the one I hate for
hate and love but he recommended that I
leave the team and and be a Covey writer
but just for the record you two both
were outstanding Covey writers so from
from being on the ground talking to you
all saving our bacon I can set up for
the record but the moment time on that
mission for you at one point you almost
you and your pilot almost had a mere
Collision yes with an f word an F4
turned us on our side and and loosened
the
the mark and Rockets on my side of the
airplane they have had Rockets but the
the uh the rocket pod
was useless after we landed and it don't
know how it stayed on but but yes it was
close it was that close because and
people don't realize where the jet
moving several hundred miles an hour
past you just a force of that air alone
not only did your aircraft bounce but it
was damaged yes and okay so that's a
moment time so
as part of your history on August the
22nd you were down in Danang for a
promotion board
and this was this led to a major we
didn't realize on the 22nd but in the
early morning hours of the 23rd there
was a severe attack on fob4 into Nang
and you had gone downtown to our safe
house that night and you came back in
the morning to see the Carnage yes and
if you could talk a little bit about
how after the Viet Cong MVA sappers had
planned an attack for over a year they
launched it in early light early morning
no Moonlight and they ultimately killed
16 Green Berets at that base and others
and we lost dozens of indigenous and the
nv80 came in were headbands and said we
came to die and they did
and so after that night of fighting you
came in what did you see at IFA before
well we were at house 22 which was a
a safe house and and I
they were showing a movie at at
fob four and I told Pat Watkins that we
ran to the uh to the uh Transit hooches
which were partial partially being built
but we wanted to get close to the shower
uh the rooms closest to the shower were
already occupied one of the rooms that
we liked when we were down there we
stayed at before was near the shower and
Lieutenant Potter was already in there
and a couple of the others yeah well
that is like having a Charmed life
because
that room was destroyed and Lieutenant
Potter was killed and is better and in
his bed right there at that at that
point but we moved down the hall and I
put my rucksack in there and then I said
hey
yep said hey Pat
why don't you let me
take your your Swedish K automatic nine
millimeter with me because you know I'm
going down there and there's some bad
guys out that way I said you guys are
going to be here you know and and he he
had a 45 caliber pistol I had a I had a
38 because it was in my uh
my uh the Air Force flight vest and I
was hey you'd when I got back off a
mission said you're going down to the
promotion board and of course I didn't
get to bring any
clean fatigues or anything down there I
just got my I usually carried my car 15
and Hand Grenades and all that like down
there with a 38 and six loose rounds and
and I so I had uh I had Watkins two
magazines in a in a and a
Swedish K yeah so I took that down at
about
I guess about 2 30 3 o'clock in the
morning we got we got a guy a couple of
guys tried to get into house 22 and and
the gate guards there fired them up then
we got the word that that fob 4 and 6cn
was Under Fire we got on a three-quarter
ton
and drove
to there at the as morning was breaking
and they let us in we went up by the uh
went up by the dispensary where people
were laid out there there were still
fire there's still sappers we went down
to the fence line I ran into Watkins and
of course he hugged me and then then
wanted to strangle me because I had his
automatic weapon he had to use this 45
yeah
what happened to Watkins and Varney
Varney was on the chopper with us they
they were smart enough to hide behind
their mattresses when the uh when the
sapper rolled a hand grenade down the
hallway and blew it in and then Pat went
outside and killed that Snapper with his
45 then
they got they got behind some uh
I guess it was a some sand piles or or
sandbags and then Watkins told me that
they were getting fire from the combo
bunker
and uh
uh there was a captain
Pfeiffer who had thrown a grenade over
maybe 50 yards or yeah long distance
yeah long distance and and uh
borney had got up to to tell the people
inside the combo blockers they were
Americans but they were already sappers
in there and he got shot so he was
killed and and uh Watkins and I went on
down after Sunrise we were down like
Just Before Sunrise I guess there were
some there was two the NBA
sappers when their uh line Lauren cloths
and and they were in our latrines right
our wooden you know
trained yeah and they had locked arms
and they were getting fired up I believe
Doug Godshall had walked down there with
us because we were picking up stragglers
there was no organized uh
organized defense as as you would have
it and Watkins took charge of that he
said hey we're going to go here we got
to prepare for a counter attack nobody
thought I didn't think about a
counter-attack but he did and he said
you know he said we're gonna we we took
these stragglers down in the firing
inside that
that [ __ ] yeah and it blew apart they
had laid together and pulled the pin on
a hand grenade and killed themselves now
those guys were dedicated they were you
know oh yeah of course
to them that was their mission and it
was worth dying for we can you know we
were doing the same things we didn't
want to die but you know when it come to
it you know you and I we had our sop
we had our final rounds we had our we
had our nine millimeters we had our hand
grenades and uh you know not going to be
taken alive
so that
when you fighting those kind of people I
mean grudgingly
respect that hey
they did what what they were fighting
for however uh you know why didn't I
have no remorse in squeezing the trigger
so yes that uh so you're there for that
historic moment yes for that there was
Lynn black you know I should have been
there but I I would have probably been
in Lieutenant Potter's book but anyway I
believe I've had a Charmed uh life
without a question and then two days
after
October 5th I'm biased on this just to
wander for a second you and Pat Walkers
again as cubby Riders we're over our
team when we finally made contact with
you all and you provided the great
coverage for us coordinated the air and
again we got out last night with the
captain 10 pulling us out
and then other moments in time which
would include Christmas Day
which was one of the most unusual uh
Transmissions I ever have it's on the
ground we're in contact and you said we
got an Intel report do not go through
the Northeast and you would talk to the
Frenchman yes yeah I remember that
yeah he said don't move don't move a
hair tell those guys you know tell those
guys just don't tell them why because
you know another thing that we we didn't
pay enough attention to is the ability
of the NVA to rdef they they were
Masters at that you know after a few
Transmissions
yeah so they were able to triangulate if
they had if you were on the FM radio for
just a short amount of time like Doug's
case he wanted to remain clandestine
well he he gave me the right info and
and he said just relay it and I said yes
sir private
you and Doug Letourneau were probably
pfcs right so
um we'll go fast ahead for for one week
on New Year's Eve 68 team is inserted
you went out gave them a team okay you
came back a little bit concerned
uh because it was New Year's Eve we
won't talk about your concerns but you
came back and in the morning you flew
out early again to check in with the
team and that was where one of the first
times we had a Recon team on the ground
hit by sappers yeah and so again this is
another one of those sad but historic
moments So you you're directly involved
I was on the radio with I believe that
was labone
or who is the other but halls and Hall
Haas because we knew Halls they were
Canadians they were but he he said wait
and I heard
AK fire in the background and I've just
started shaking my head because I never
got another transmission from him wow
and that's where the whole team
uh
there were no indeeds killed is that
right correct yep and and that fine
Crew Chief from the 101st that went down
on the string and tied the bodies
no I wasn't I forgotten that part well
they took them down to to uh to fob4 and
remember Colonel one you got to talk you
but there we've got too many stories
yeah well these are the socks throughs
that you were directly involved in yes
and and more and more and so I would
we've gone through some of that and so
for your remaining Tour of Duty you and
I were together at fob4 at CCN after
they closed after B1 but I saw them saw
you because you're busy doing what down
there you're wrapping up your tour Duty
up on chin strap up where uh uh up up
where uh
uh
Larry trimble's team was up there and I
was up there with another fob I didn't
want to hang around the headset I
thought I'd get hey you'd again indeed
and you know what hey you is for our
audiences you know you're standing
around doing nothing and uh
you can explain it better than me but
you've been hey you yeah you have too
Tom
and uh so from here I'd like to go back
to something we skirted over when you're
talking maybe we can't go into too much
detail now but
you when you were in Bogota there was
another this is a changing gears we're
going from SOG now to years later
you're in Bogota and you quickly
mentioned the Hall of Justice had been
overrun by terrorists
and you were there at that moment in
time
could you talk just like that guy I
wasn't there when it happened but I got
there later on because it's kind of like
when I got into fob4 you know a Charmed
Life
indeed but that was a moment in time
where you're still were you still with
the third or seventh then the 37 okay
and so you're down there and that was
where the terrorists took over the Hall
of Justice and Bogota I killed the
justices yes they executed I don't know
how many uh Supreme Court Justices but
of the assignments I've had till uh the
third of the seventh and the duty up in
El Salvador either other countries
training their armies training their uh
civilian Defense Forces uh go into
Argentina getting to travel on the
parachute team to ever country in
Central and South America except Chile
the third of the seventh of the two
tours I had there the tour in in the
first group in the first of the first in
Okinawa
finest assignments I've had except for
The Wanted fubai
yeah that was a little different yeah a
little different but nonetheless that's
a special forces career that's really
your two mods to stay up but I'll say is
exemplary and that's why we're here
today and I'm just honored to have you
with us to talk about that and you know
during that time you also spent the time
in Korea
and I remember there was at least one
poster that was made from May 6 like 98
or 99 when you had participated in a
major jump your jump demonstration team
had jumped into Korea
and you had talked a little bit about
your time in Korea with another unique
assignment
well I
I left Panama just before just cause
oh is that right yes okay and by the way
one of my
one of my
uh acquaintances one of my jump
Personnel or jump trainees was Manuel
norjega he had he had yes I have
pictures of that to prove that but
Manuel would was a skydiver and he
loaned us his aircraft for a weekend
practice jumps along with the Panamanian
jump team really yes
but I'd also had made friends with some
famous skydivers in Korea and we had a
Commander's cup jump in in Korea I got
to meet
a lot of Korean uh
uh uh high-ranking officers and their
special Warfare folks and of course
sfdk Special Forces Detachment Korea
took me under their wing and and allowed
me to jump with him
as a reservist so
I retired reserves anyway
I I hope that wouldn't compromise any of
the people in that time frame but I was
assigned as The Garrison
sergeant major is a command sergeant
major Camp Page Korea and they had a a
fine compound there
then later on after I retired I became a
Garrison commander of Camp Hialeah in
Busan Korea so but those are those are
two longest stories and and uh it's just
you know some of the guys in Alabama
said that hey spider
you Forrest Gump
anyway
I said I can back it up okay so uh but
I'm about worn out let's wind this thing
up till we're gonna well we will in a
few minutes here but you know I think
that the after your time in the army
there's also a period where your service
to our country and then to veterans
where you went on to get high get
educated
you became a Dr Parks
and then you worked with the VA for 15
years working with veterans well I
didn't work with the VA I worked for the
Department of army as a behavioral
scientist a substance abuse professional
testing training uh education and
therapy but that that took a long time
but but remember this I came back in the
Army I was on my way to be a public
health professional I had served in
every Department of the Dallas City and
County this is before you before I yes
but before before I came back on 67 to
go get my uh
my the toughest course I ever took was
the Special Forces oh and I but I was
going to school at night the the the
department was educating me and grooming
me to be a public health officer officer
I worked with meat milk food
investigation Animal Control vector
control VD investigation really yes
really uh uh
and and it was a
you know it was it was an interesting
occupation I had planned to go do a year
in Vietnam and come back to the health
department but something happened
the bonding the Phyllis the fellowship
and knowing that
I get to travel I get to go to language
school I get all this
I'm not going back to Dallas Texas
here's another thing I was born at the
hospital
that John F Kennedy died at Parkland
Parkland Hospital I was downtown in City
Hall when he got shot really yes and one
of the officers that got killed was a
high school friend of mine
and in nineteen
eighty eighty one
his son was in my company in the 82nd
Airborne when I was the first sergeant
in the 82nd
and he was killed by his wife so oh wow
this
this story could go on so the 82nd was
part of your career yes
yeah we became a command sergeant major
and how many different posts did you
actually serve as a command sergeant
major
I actually uh Panama and Korea Camp Page
and the third of the seventh in Panama
that's the only two only two yeah only
two yeah again it's outstanding and the
the modesty Factor here and then uh
continuing on the last 15 years through
your American Legion Post in Huntsville
again you're on a special detail there
where you continue to go to honor our
veterans when they pass away in fact you
had a funeral yesterday did you not
or two days ago the day before yesterday
yes sir and in the 13 years we've done
over 1200 funerals for veterans I serve
as the deputy commander of the post 237
American Legion Honor Guard indeed
and uh and I'm also on the powmia team
for the joint Special Operations
yesterday hey I got too many stories
well that's we're we're not complaining
about that and then uh the the other
side of the spider coin did we didn't
talk about at all too was
you've played a little Sports in your
day so even when you're in high school
in ninth grade because back in your
school as a way they were transitioning
to a new high school you as a ninth
grader wound up in high school and
you're on the football team
and
you went on to have a career in
athletics that's where we met playing
softball but still you've played
football baseball and many years playing
fast pitch long after most fast pitchers
have retired how to play baseball in
Korea
yeah they played on a minor league
baseball team in Korea up until my late
60s wow so well mid 60s uh played on
semi-pro football team in in Pittsburgh
Leominster their first year what's that
right yep we were at Taft group at Fort
Evans yep that's right indeed they uh
they played teams like the Long Island
Bulls the uh
played Park League teams in in Boston
and the prison team I remember that out
in out in Concord so yeah
it's been a wonderful life too it has
and uh you're part of a very unique
niche in history during an eight-year
secret War you served in that war for
your year put your time in with many
amazing Stories and there are people
that are alive today thanks to your
service you and Pat Watkins when you're
flying as a copywriters and uh
I know that uh you're inclined to wrap
it up here but as we do so
as you reflect back on those years
you've also had a personal
effort I don't know how much detail we
can go into but for example the Hat
you're wearing today is unique because
that hat has traveled to you it's a
special operations Association hat
that has traveled with you when you went
to Laos when you returned to Vietnam in
an effort to
try to help any way at all
to locate our team members team members
and at least it remains and uh you
travel at least back there once with
Tony Harrell yes and if you could maybe
just talk a little bit about that
because that gives a reflection of your
commitment and devotion
to our teammates that we lost in 1968.
well of course
The Haunting experience and the uh the
personal
uh passion that I have for wanting to
find the guy that replaced me for when I
should have been on that mission and
Glenn Laden what a great
base he gave me as a to be a 1-0
that's you know that's that's a passion
that I I can't deny and I have been able
to travel uh
many times
uh due to uh
due to uh
due to my health and due to having
enough made enough money and having
enough funds donated to to allow me to
travel and I have a have a couple of
businesses one in one in the Philippines
and and one in Korea and I've had help
from many different people over there I
have decided that
that I want to dedicate my life to
humanitarian efforts and instead of
trying to bomb and kill people but I you
know I can go into that
as you know philosophically but that
would take probably the rest of the day
till and and you know we need to wrap it
up we do and uh but also from our first
hand basis you and I were together in
the ashaw valley
and you have since returned her where
now there's a hotel yes yeah that used
to be a Green Beret a camp they now have
a hotel yeah the a Louis Airfield and
and uh tabat Airfield I've crash landed
on on uh Louis and you can see that from
the weekend Market where the hotel lives
in the ash owl rally and they've got
paved parts of the of of the hotel Ho
Chi Minh trail no yes now you said you
crash landed there in an 0-2 yes the
front engine was shot out
just another day and another day and
nothing another day and you know another
day and now I'm man indeed and then also
uh as we close out you have uh dabbled
with music a little bit and you've put
together a couple songs that uh although
we're not we may not have the link today
but we'll post it where people can go to
songs that you've composed
um and that music
you've tied it into SOG and the couple
to Recon and who is the story about you
gaining some of your early inspiration
free music came in 1968 and from two
unique men
could use us before we wrap up could you
share a little bit of that and then how
we if people are interested in Spider
songs where we can lead them to at some
point until you were in that room with
me when we were playing the guitars you
remember the chaplain played guitar I
remember Grady spry famous Airborne
chaplain used to drink a six pack of
beer and and play country western and of
course
I was interested in country western and
rock but they were don't forget back
then the headsets were only one a year
yeah so in one ear I had the Vanilla
Fudge in the cream the doors and other
year I'm listening to you guys through
country country western so I had a very
dichotomist I played more more country
rather more rock and roll
these two gentlemen who were younger
than me younger than you I believe uh
stand uh
seating and Richard Fitz who took money
from me in a poker game by the way oh
okay well well his son became a rock
star Richard Fitz Jr yeah and I played
with him also is that right at sore you
saw me sitting over there that's a long
time ago yeah anyway long term fifths
could play the guitar and sing yes stay
and seating
likewise and we played rock songs and we
changed the words to them because we
were in the now man we're in Vietnam
yeah but the high-heeled sneakers
you know so give us a little bit of a
hint of that
high heel sneaker instead of putting on
your high heel sneakers you put on a put
on your Flak Jacket present because
we're going down the trail or we're
going out tonight put on your steel pot
brothers because we're going out to
fight and we put that to the tune uh put
on your high heel sneakers and the other
song I kind of put in one of a of a
progression of cards that I used for the
Black Rifle coffee song that's right I
forgot but I I had that that progression
for
don't go down that trail it's a Highway
to Hell and you know that's part of our
sop don't go down in the trail that's
right don't cut down no grass it might
show where we passed you know but stuff
like that that's sort of you know I've
had a penchant for that I'm not any good
I got a scratchy voice and an out of
tune guitar
but maybe we'll have to connect you with
the uh the folks that put together the
sog video game solid prayer for our
video game because they're always
looking for music well that you know
I'm from
my my musician partner and the brains of
the outfit Randy grave was an Army
musician he's been on the he's on the
honor guard for post 229 we have
combined because we didn't have enough
old people to do funerals oh is that
right yeah wow well and so what we'll do
is uh I'll play you a couple of songs
we'll get through here
very good and then what we'll do is um
uh we'll uh get that music and get the
word out and I will talk to people from
Savage games that put together the sog
prairie fire video game that's now out
on the market based off it and pays
homage to to SOG and the men that were
in it and we will go forward with that
from now this should be a tribute to the
memory of of the stand seating and
Richard Fitz and we
we're not Randy and I are not doing this
for money we're doing it for historical
preservation indeed and uh uh we have to
say that Richard Fitz was one of seven
Green Berets who were killed November
30th 1968.
they were on an elder-sun Mission which
was a mission Arthur Vader art Bader was
there from New Jersey uh he's the man I
remember the most I remember Fitz
because he took money from me in a poker
game yeah but art Bader I remember him
because of his New Jersey link and he
was at 67 and and with us at Fort Bragg
also is that right see I've forgotten
that but yep I got him out of jail
I forgot that too so what would happen
so on that mission though
November 30th Richard Fitz went down
with the king bee and their remains
weren't uh recovered until like 20 plus
years later but they are now resting
let's talk about Richard's junior or
Richard's son uh he has a video and he
has a memorial to that it's called
23 years in a folded flag something like
that and we may see him this October we
hope so at the Special Operations
Association reunion in Vegas and uh
before we have a final any final closing
thoughts from you sir
thank you
and with that
we want to thank all the veterans out
there today men like Robert J Spider
Parks who fought for the ideals of our
country truly an American Hero
to those of you out there
on the front lines now we thank you for
fighting for all that we care for for
our values today
and this recording is September the 2nd
and it's been a more difficult time in
our country's history with Afghanistan
and the families that are caught up in
all of this are service members we space
as best we pay special tribute to them
as well as all of our service members
police law enforcement border patrol
Secret Service
and we're going to thanks to all who
live and for those who did not return
we have a special salute for them
and for those that didn't come home
and today we close out again we thank
spider parks
thank you for your service to our
country sir and to all our people out
there today
God Bless America amen
and now for one of my favorite duties
with our top secret agent
our technician Tom who we can't feel as
identity because obvious reasons he's
just too busy these days but most
importantly we're here now to talk about
sawcast number 12 with one of my
all-time Brothers
friend man Mentor
Etc Robert J Spider Parks so what was
your impression sir for the first time
to meet the live and live our living
legend
it was amazing as usual meeting any of
the any of the guys from SOG for me but
uh Spider especially because I've read
so many
so many books and everywhere in there in
every book I think I've read yeah is
spider parks and it was like
meeting a legend you know it's like I've
met him here's the legend you know and
it it's great it's it's Heroes like him
uh and yourself and the others that were
with you that you know is a reason that
people do what they do you know it's
inspirational that he continues uh you
know all of the all the stuff that he's
doing yeah I mean like he
served in the Army for 30 years he
doesn't even hardly talk or want to talk
now and yeah we barely scratched the
surface but I figure it's Bears crossed
the surface than not to get on the
surface at all yeah you know it and I
know it's got to be hard even still to
this day for him to talk about
um with George and it was interesting to
get the confirmation so if you haven't
listened to
sogcast101 yeah if you haven't listened
to that one listen to that one and then
listen to this one and you'll see that
they tie together uh so it's uh yeah
it's definitely
I know that's got to be difficult losing
you know the team that you were actually
on and not not even gone from yet but on
and uh and they went out and then you
never saw him again so
I think it's you know that's a hard part
it's is discussing that so it was good
that he he gave some insight into it and
his experiences with it obviously we
heard from the troll Mr George Sternberg
uh and what his actions were like on the
ground so it's it's interesting to to
see that well yeah and how many people I
think we can count them on about one
hand
how many people actually ran Recon with
a team lost the team
or like with Jim short and Jones yeah
who we had Saw cast number two or three
two two and uh
he had that bright light where he uh
wasn't able to get to the uh to the Air
Force F4
and years later he went back on his own
dime got chased off then he went in with
dpaa helped them yeah and then of course
dpaa being the scumbags they are screwed
him get back one more time never took
him never had the courage to call yeah
spider
is one of the few that's been back yeah
more than once physically on the LZ
where the team disappeared or where the
bright light was shot up yeah
is he going back again I thought you had
said he was trying to I don't know with
everything that's happening in the world
yeah I think there's always the desire
to go back and with world events the uh
the
virus
Etc and um I know he had to cancel at
least one trip because of the virus yeah
he had everything's set up ticks
purchased uh hotel rooms rented and just
the thought of the Astro Valley with
hotels and it was just kind of crazy
music sooner you should go there and
gamble oh yeah I mean you guys already
gambled there yeah in the Asia Valley
right you gamble with your life now you
can get with some money something that's
not as bad
yeah and then uh the the the parts of
history that he participated in yeah
good God and uh well anyways any other
closing thoughts from you observing one
of our song Legends all right no just
again it's such an honor uh to be able
to sit here and and do nothing
to to listen to this so uh and uh the
only thing I have to say is to all the
families that are out there right now
indeed
um obviously this will post later
but you know there's people still
fighting for you so keep that going you
know keep hope that's all you could say
and you know there's always people
trying to help and and you know
keep that hope that they're going to
help you indeed
well thank you sir and thank you for
helping today and uh with that one more
time we want to thank Jocko Echo Charles
and his team for productions for doing
our Saw cast without them we couldn't do
it
and like you said
um this particular Moment In Time
September 2nd 2021
it's a unique moment in our country's
history and any of the families that
hear this
you will remain in our prayers the 13
families that paid the Supreme price
that became gold star families you will
remain our thoughts and prayers you will
not be forgotten
as we move forward we thank those who
are putting their lives on the line
every day for our country
and uh last but not least
um
was September
the third Friday of September is the
national pow Mia recognition day
where from the Vietnam War
we've had that recognition day that's
been a part of our history often not
given much attention but the league of
pow Mia families always does so and if
you're ever looking for donations to
help they still are there they work with
our government they pressure the
government they work with the economists
in an effort to help to return locate
fine and return to our country the
1583
of people service members
that are missing an answer from the
Vietnam War which includes Vietnam Laos
Cambodia North Vietnam Thailand and
China
there's a few there and with that
thought we want to salute those who did
not come home
and
hope we continue to bring more remains
back
thank you to Jocko and his team
God Bless America